let's say that we want to take 14 and
divide it by 70 so clearly this is going
to be a number less than 114 is clearly
less than 70 but let's try to do it so
immediately we say okay 70 goes into 1
zero times so that's not going to work
out 70 goes into 14 well it doesn't go
into 14 any time so we're going to have
to add some decimal places so let's do
that let's add a decimal place right
over here make sure we put the decimal
right over there but now we can think of
it as 70 goes into 140 how many times
well 70 goes into 142 times two times
and two times 70 is 140 and you subtract
and you are left with no remainder so
you're done you can write that 14
divided by 70 is exactly equal to 0.2
let's do a slightly more involved
example like this so let's say I wanted
to divide let's say I wanted to divide I
want to divide oh I don't know let's
let's do a little more interesting let's
divide 16 let's divide 16 by I don't
know let's divide it by 25 and see what
we get so initially we say okay 25
doesn't go into 1 it doesn't go into 16
we're going to have to add some decimals
right over here how many times does 25
go into 160 make sure we put the decimal
above it so let's see 25 times 4 is 125
times 6 is 150 so that looks right so it
goes 6 times 6 times 25 is is 1 20 plus
30 which is 150 and now we can subtract
and 160 minus 150 is 10 and now we just
bring down one more zero we add one more
place value notice we're not changing
the value 16 is the same thing as 16
point zero which is the same thing 16
point zero zero so now you bring down
this 0 right over here and how many
times does 25 go into 100 well we know
it goes exactly 4 times 4 times 25 is
100 and we are done we have nothing left
to keep dividing with so we can say that
Dean divided by 25 is equal to 0.6 for